plett à monsieur guy teissier merci
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
j'associe mes collègues valérie boyer et
dominique étions l'un d'eux concerne la
terrible agression à coups de machette
père péter hier par un jeune adolescent
de moins deux saisons à l'encontre d'un
enseignant de l'école juive la source
qui situe à marseille dans ma
circonscription je tiens bien sûr tout
d'abord adresser de nouveau tout mon
soutien à la victime ainsi qu'à ses
proches alors qu'il se rendait à pied
vers l'établissement où il dispense des
cours de théologie
le professeur pendant une kippa a été
adressée par le jeune homme qui avait la
ferme intention de tuer suivant ses
propres dires la victime qui s'est
défendu indiqué aux enquêteurs avoir vu
beaucoup de haine dans les yeux de ce
jeune garçon
heureusement un riverain a fait fuir
l'agresseur
ce qui fait frémir en plus de cet acte
odieux et révoltant c'est la description
de l'auteur qui revendique clairement
son acte d'antisémitisme au nom d'allah
et de dèche et sa haine des juifs
il s'agit d'un adolescent de nationalité
turque et d'origine kurde
présenté comme un bon élève totalement
inconnu des services de police et de
justice
le procureur a annoncé qu'il serait
radicalisé il se serait radicalisé via
internet
sa famille semblait absolument ignorer
sa radicalisation et une fin quand t'es
pas la mosquée alors que la section
antiterroriste du parquet de paris a été
saisie de la sphère monsieur le premier
ministre
quels moyens supplémentaires pouvons
nous développer pour parvenir à
identifier ces jeunes qui finalement se
situe hors radars ce et qui se
radicalise sur internet leurs graves
cet acte inqualifiable ces actes se
multiplient en novembre un professeur
d'histoire d'une école juive de
marseille avait été blessé à coups de
couteau
mon auparavant d'octobre un déséquilibré
avait adressé de fidèles et un rabbin
chaque agression de ce type
la crainte même de la subir est en soi
une tache sur le drapeau tricolore
une injure faite à la république il est
urgent de renforcer la sécurité des
personnes et même que l'ancien abords
des lieux publics monsieur le ministre
les parents d'élèves des familles juives
merci monsieur tessier la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député tessier
merci pour cette question qui dans la
relation qu'elle fait de ce qui s'est
produit à marseille air est parfaitement
précise est tout à fait exact et
correspond aux informations qui m'ont
été communiquées d'abord je veux
m'associer à vos propos
pour dire la condamnation la plus ferme
de toute la représentation nationale et
bien entendu du gouvernement elle s'est
exprimée hier à l'égard de la
monstruosité de ses actes antisémites
qui sont une véritable blessure pour les
français de confession juive
une blessure irréparable car le
traumatisme occasionné suscite des
souffrances qui dure longtemps et j'ai
eu hier soir le professeur qui est
victime de cette agression au téléphone
et je veux confirmer son traumatisme sa
peine son incompréhension et en même
temps la grande dignité de la communauté
juive qui s'est exprimé hier qui
appellent toujours lorsque des
événements de ce type se produisent à la
concorde et à la fraternité parce que ce
sont des valeurs que portent les juifs
de france magnifiquement et que je veux
rappeler ici à l'occasion de la réponse
à votre question alors vous me dites que
peut-on faire
le profil de celui qui a frappé hier est
très caractéristique de ces jeunes
vulnérables qui se radicalise par la
fréquentation d'internet qu'avons nous
fait et quels résultats vont nous obtenu
d'ores et déjà
premièrement nous avons pris des
dispositions dans la loi du 13 novembre
2014 qui permet le blocage administratif
des sites qui appelle et provoque au
terrorisme ce sont plus de 100 sites que
nous avons bloqué 115 adresses internet
et de nombreux sites qui ont été bloqués
ont fait l'objet de poursuites
judiciaires c'est indispensable de faire
ce travail parce que beaucoup de ceux
qui se radicalise se radicalise par la
fréquentation de ses sites
et puis nous avons mis en place dans la
loire enseignement la détection sur
données anonymes qui permettra par le
travail des services de renseignements
de mieux identifier le comportement de
ceux qui fréquentent ces sites de les
identifier et de les empêcher d'agir
c'était parfois de surveillance
l'état